[Music]
is anyone here familiar with uh the way
that they do death penalties in egypt
they do uh mine they [ __ ] mummify
your ass
that sounds very very fun and they pull
their brains out of your nose oh yeah
with the scooper whoa that's creative
and disgusting
you actually do do that pull your brains
out of your nose yeah how do you do that
[ __ ] yeah
how do you do that i don't remember it
was a crazy ass
i thought they take you to the tip of
the pyramid and they spike your ass on
it and just go wow
this video right now spin you yeah all
the time creative um all of you are
wrong
um the organs outside so that your body
doesn't spoil that bad
let's go ahead and just give some
pictures and see if we can keep on
guessing what happened none of us were
right
hanging i'm going to say the pictures
staring contest staring contest
guess a story
her ex-boyfriend
[ __ ] was mad and then she said i'm
gonna hang you
she wow she wore a skirt
is she is she egyptian she's egyptian
really how did you know she was an
egyptian lover she looks like america
okay so basically what happened oh [ __ ]
though all right is this chicks like
cleopatra you're right this chick's name
is naira ashraf i'm gonna i
actually was
killed in a very gruesome way wow by a
dude named mohammed adele oh
adele t okay they were fellas i love
adele
that's what he took from it
maybe adel i don't know
why they gotta do adele's name like that
no yeah that's a bad rapper he killed
her
student
because she rejected his advances oh my
god [ __ ] off dude ultimate reddit incel
after she refused to marry him
the 21 year old organized a gruesome
plot to kill her outside of mansour
university just before she was due to
sit on her exams
wow and
the killer stabbed her repeatedly
jumped on her and slit her throat in
front of everyone who was outside the
university holy [ __ ] the [ __ ] so man
pleads guilty and he's given the death
penalty right
but because of the heinous nature of
this woman's murder the court of that
area wants to make an example that's
fire they gotta do this more that's true
so they want to hang him mm-hmm on
public national television
put it on twitch and i'll donate and
then stab him at the same time
i'll give 5 000 bits yeah i do i feel
like hanging is just too easy because
she preach he literally like split her
throat in front of everybody that's true
a lot of a lot of maybe ladies that got
uh domestically abused they could be the
[ __ ] what do you call it the grip not
the the guy the the
executioner
if you were the queen of egypt how would
you yeah if you're cleo cleo julia cleo
julia very good oh nice i was gonna go
there but that's interesting yeah uh
so i think i'll probably start off with
him sitting in a chair and just giving
him micro cuts very slowly micro cuts
where just everywhere everywhere with
the razor blades you'd be paying him a
lot of attention i think he likes that
no no no because like it would it
wouldn't be it wouldn't be comfortable
at all whatsoever and not even
pleasurable it would just be
slow pain but don't you think that he'd
be like see a woman's doing this i knew
they were the worst
have you ever been to that reddit it's
like reddit the what the [ __ ] is it
called it's like these dudes who are
like they think women are just a scam
it's a bad
they think that women are a [ __ ] scam
dude
women are a ponzi school they're like
once you once you marry a woman the day
the next day they lose 30 percent of the
value
don't get a new one when you get a used
one it's like a bmw yeah exactly don't
drive it off the lot no i'll do so we'll
do tiny cuts it'll be like multiple
people at once doing tiny cuts and then
we'll break off his fingers one by one
yeah obviously sorry
pull out the nails and then break the
fingers
you start small and go big yeah yeah and
then you break the toes i like it i'm a
pain sled actually yeah well when you
break the ankle the pain [ __ ] what are
you gonna do oh man that's just coming
i don't care just keep breaking bones
you just break bones can i help i guess
i'll just keep on coming all over the
place yeah
and then
stab them
thank you yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna bust
out a hammer i'm gonna play m c hammer's
hammer time and go hammer time and i'm
gonna start smashing him
dog style you know
he doesn't say hammer time that much
though
he just isn't getting off he really he
really does he really builds it up yeah
but he doesn't say it that much he'll
just keep saying it yeah okay
because when you say stop how much time
that's actually one of my break it break
is i go stop
how about time
no the o it's over for the guy then yeah
yeah yeah and then i'll just have him
get stabbed in places where it's not
that critical but he's just bleeding oh
non-critical stabs how long so that like
huh how long is the knife um i don't
know
razor blade or like a big like maybe
they're like this long and then you just
twist it
like a potato peeler yeah yeah yeah yeah
and then and then at the point when he's
like what happened
oh okay i don't i don't know if we'll
actually get to the hanging because i
feel like that's just letting him off
easy we don't need to get today we can
get to the flame speaking of the hanging
yeah when you see this in actuality are
you like as part of like a public
display do you think that that will help
like dudes like this not do this
yeah
[ __ ]
what do you think do you think it'll
create more of a copycat type of deal no
i i actually think that it probably will
too but i was curious to hear a woman's
perspective i think they're hanging him
i like the i like the old-school uh
punishment you know how they tie like a
guy to a horse and they just smack oh
yeah just [ __ ] take off dude just
getting dragged on [ __ ] dirt and
gravel i think they're hanging him from
the wrong side of the body what they
need to do is have you seen the rope
sex [ __ ] that they tie up all the
japanese girls they [ __ ] time up and
hang
and then when they drop him he's hanging
by the dick and it tears out of his body
and he falls to the ground oh he's still
alive but the [ __ ] dick is hanging
on the ground and he's wiggling wiggling
around who do you think he's got to be
the person that like has to do the knot
around his penis though
oh i'll do it right here yeah whoa scout
you dude i'm pretty good at it there's
plenty of volunteers this is a conflict
no it's not it's purely business okay it
feels okay it's not i won't i won't let
that interfere with my work i'm gonna
get a [ __ ] fish hook put it through
his [ __ ] and then make it come out of
his [ __ ] scrotum wow that's pretty
good yeah
you make a nice little plump sized hole
right here by his organs
any time he grunts in pain another organ
comes out
and it just like it just falls out and
it just keeps falling out because you
can't keep it in wow because every time
you go
it just like
spills out so then his entrails are
outside of his body i like when the
intros are out that's like some old
times and one of the most painful things
like i think research has shown is organ
failure damn
you just let a little liver go bye bye
hello pain paradise
i'm scared of god nothing even knows
that stat like
put some
cayenne pepper on his liver and he goes
what about some garlic powder taste buds
you guys want to know what i think would
actually be justice
actual justice
you put them in a dress
you are like hey
wanna make you like to have sex or like
you know you go on a date and then
obviously he's like no
and then you just start [ __ ] them
yeah start [ __ ] [ __ ] him against
themselves that would probably hurt him
[ __ ] when he [ __ ] [ __ ]
i'm into male rape dude i'm into that oh
you know what and then on record dude it
actually makes sense that honestly does
make more sense to give him some kind of
punishment that feels like it'll
restrict his access to whatever
afterlife he believes in yeah
he's not going to get his 32 versions no
more that's true 70 or something that's
all you do no well because of inflation
1700 virgins dude i'll make them fall in
love with because you know when some
people believe that the crime they
committed was a just one so they don't
feel like it'll affect their actual
standing in the cause he might think he
did just did like an honor killing or
i'm still tight i don't care i'm still
tight good
on his ear
he's gonna ascend into a high five with
someone like in the clouds and [ __ ] well
nick dunn's making him open downtown
i got you something sweetheart i can
barely read it because it rails hard
[ __ ] hair back the whole time
so just to throw some extra stats in
there between 2016 and 2018 there were
at least 103 executions carried out in
egypt public how many kind of fire bro
uh not necessarily all public
those figures are rough because egypt
doesn't publicly release the number of
executions and human rights groups are
left to estimate dude human rights kick
rocks
stop being [ __ ]
let them do their thing yeah what do you
know about egyptian culture yeah single
day in 2020 there was a whopping 75
people sentenced to death and 47 others
were given life behind bars for a single
uh for being members of a terrorist
group
egypt has one of the highest rates of
executions along with iran saudi arabia
vietnam and iraq
vietnam vietnam yeah but you know what
you know you know what's sick about the
egyptians yeah let's tell them see while
the hangman's walking to the news he's
like
all the stereotypes
that's how they do it it's 100 percent
fact this is historical fact building
human rights groups have said
and he has the mask on in the
hieroglyphics they're just documenting
history they do that's how they want
is there a correlative uh evidence that
like countries that have the most um
death like
deaths through the court system are
actually more like preventative for
certain crimes
i don't think it shows anything like
that yeah
or are they just like killing more
people
what's amazing is if is if you look at
how they built the pyramids they had to
[ __ ] walk like this the whole time
you